ce soir à 21h France 2 consacrera une
émission à Jean-Luc Mélenchon durant 90
minutes Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'est ni
député ni ministre mais il aura les
honneurs du service public il sera en
direct de la Guyane française au coeur
de la forêt amazonienne avec tous les
moyens techniques de France Télévisions
à 7
1 et remplaçables
je pense que je suis remplaçable j'ai
pas vu la cohue pour pour prendre le
poste alors je préfère le dire je suis
remplaçable évidemment et je le souhaite
remplacé attendez et je le souhaite et
j'ai pris toutes les dispositions pour
le faire la présentatrice Caroline Roux
les journalistes les techniciens tous ce
petit monde et du voyage avec l'argent
du contribuable pour dérouler le tapis
rouge très rouge même à celui qui n'a
aucune fonction aucun titre aucun mandat
dans la République je ne vous parle même
pas du bilan carbone d'un tel voyage
avec au minimum une cinquantaine de
salariés de France 2 délocalisés là j'ai
juste envie d'en tuer un ou deux tu vois
parce que voilà quand tu vois ça ça te
met ça te met les nerfs quoi je sais pas
moi un moment donné
[Musique]
c'est pas vrai au sérieux achetez-vous
un cerveau la France vous ne serez pas
candidat quoi qu'il arrive en 2027 vous
voulez que je vous signale un papier et
si jamais je mets le moindre doute
moi je ne trouve pas choquant qu'on
fasse une émission avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon alors voilà
et de dire que c'est dire n'importe quoi
je ne dis pas qu'ils font une émission
sur Jean-Luc Mélenchon arrêtez de dire
n'importe quoi je dis qu'il a faut en
Guyane
c'est pas la même chose
c'est pas la même chose excusez-moi tu
délocalise tout le monde tu le fais même
pas pour le président de la République
va falloir
et le prochain qui klaxonne il va voir
où je lui m'éclaxon dans le P2 il fera
des signal sonores ces images vous
risquez bien de les revoir de les
revivre prochainement souvenez-vous
l'automne dernier de ces stations sans
gouttes d'essence des fils d'attentats
terminables et de ses heures passées
pour trouver désespérément du carburant
car dans les raffineries et des peaux
pétroliers la CGT vient de lancer un
appel à la grève contre la réforme des
retraites un coup dur pour certains
automobilistes
concrètement les syndicats CGT de la
branche pétrole P3 prévoit pardon une
action en trois temps une première grève
de 24 heures jeudi prochain ce sera le
19 janvier puis une deuxième grève le
jeudi suivant celle-ci durera 48 heures
enfin le lundi 6 février et l'appel à la
grève et cette fois est allé sur trois
jours les salariés se verront alors
proposer la grève reconductible avec si
nécessaire l'arrêt des raffineries le 19
je vous l'assure vu les remontées de
terrain sera massif il y aura beaucoup
de collègues dans le monde de
l'éducation et dans la fonction publique
en grève et dans les manifestations ce
matin lors d'un déplacement Elisabeth
borne appelle les syndicats à la
responsabilité il y a un droit de grève
et un droit de manifester mais je pense
que c'est important aussi de ne pas
pénaliser les Français
[Musique]
l'accès de colère d'un client d'un hôtel
de luxe à Shanghai chaîne un chinois de
28 ans à saccager le hall de
l'établissement avec sa voiture après
une altercation avec des membres du
personnel l'homme les teneurs
responsables de la disparition de son
ordinateur portable plutôt que de mettre
une étoile à l'hôtel sur Internet il est
revenu à bord de son véhicule comme le
montre ses vidéos diffusé sur les
réseaux sociaux l'incident n'a fait
aucun blessé et le client a fini par
être interpellé et remis à la police à
la une de ce 12 janvier le mois sans
alcool qui se poursuit moi sans alcool
auquel Laurence Ferrari a choisi de ne
pas participer
un homme mission de d'éduquer nos
enfants merci beaucoup sanislas
un jeune homme qui a piéger Damien Rieux
ex-candidat reconquête au législatives
en lui envoyant une capture d'écran d'un
homme priant au tribunal judiciaire de
Paris je voulais démontrer à partir de
cette petite vidéo que tu te fous bien
de notre gueule
excuse le militant d'extrême droite de
propager de fausses informations et de
stigmatiser la communauté musulmane en
partageant régulièrement sur les réseaux
sociaux des photos et vidéos de
personnes en train de prier dans des
lieux publics
des petits beurre des petits beurre je
crois que c'est ça des petits beurres
et de la bière
il sort de loin celui-là je suis pas sûr
[Musique]
je dis que c'est un symptôme de
l'islamisation de mon pays selon vous de
notre pays et selon vous et c'est quoi
l'islamisation et vous vous êtes le
docteur c'est ça parce que les symptômes
de musulmans dans mon pays a été
multiplié par 1000 en 70 dollars que le
nombre de mosquées a été multiplié par
1000 en 70 ans et alors et alors j'ai
pas envie de devenir le Pakistan c'est
pas envie de devenir l'Arabie Saoudite
bienvenue
[Musique]
ça commence bien façon dès l'ouverture
de porte j'ai vu qu'ils avaient pas
envie d'être là c'était déjà bien monté
la tête c'était bien monté le bourrichon
vous la trouvez comment en pyjama il est
pas trop cute bah moi c'est pas mon
style personnellement on adore être dans
le rose mais là ça fait vraiment enfant
de 3 ans le pyjama est sympa mais c'est
la personne à l'intérieur qui est fade
pour de vrai tu m'a choqué grave grave
pourquoi tu veux que je le vois lui il
respecte qui lui maintenant le plus
important je veux te demander quelque
chose dans les pays musulmans oui
pourquoi tu as été pour faire l'humanité
parce que dans ces pays les chrétiens
notamment et les Juifs sont en danger
donc il faut les aider
voilà
vous allez où comme ça on va pas
s'asticoter pour des pâtes et un pesto
la betterave de toute façon moi
personnellement je vais pas attendre le
dessert
mais pas parce que tu me fais mal à la
tête depuis le début vas-y
je me casse toi
alors on t'entend plus
rien
allez au revoir
écoute oh non Fabrice pas vous vous
n'allez pas laisser la pauvre Jennifer
toute seule à sa pyjama party je te mets
pas dehors à poil là je suis choquée je
l'attends tourne en deux mains quoi qui
nous servent je vais le défoncer je vais
manger le dessert tout ça sera très bien
allez ciao mes amis à moi pour vous
souhaitez une très belle fin
d'après-midi sur antenne de Antenne 2